hello do you my phone charger
yeah thank you she just like a lot you
guys like riddles
I guess if you get it right before we
get to your place rides on me and sure
why not yeah you can always find me in
the past I can be created in the present
but the future will never taint me what
am i can i phone a friend
that would be cheating this is like that
CAPTCHA yeah yes
memories oh no sorry
you have arrived at your destination
well I tried oh let me get that real I
hope that was a pretty good guess
memories thank you David guesses we
could still get it for you right go go
go go go go
I'm cheating back in your seat you can
always find me in the past I could be
created in the present but the future
will never take me whatever a dream the
answer is a dream
[Music]
don't put wrong answer
what are you doing this you can always
find me
in the past I can be created in the
present but the future will never take
me what am i serious you can always find
me in the past
[ __ ] yeah no no you have arrived at your
destination
[Music]
yesterday it's yesterday it's in the
past it's not in the future you can make
it in present its yesterday it's
yesterday it's yesterday have a nice
night
Wow